N
CLAIM THAT TDEMIC WILL
SOON DISAPP A PP STILL BELIE
AT SOME PNT
IAV A VACCIN
SOON,
>> TRUMP H GRIM
ASSESSMESWN
OF F SLT
AFTER  THE
POLICE BUDGETLLMP CIAI MATTER
FIFALLING IT A OFATE THATOULD
DE LUXURYEE
IZ
FINESTE 'SIT'S
PARTIALLY  MESSAGE T THEESIDENTY
CLDENT.
IT ISOI RIGHT OSI STEP. TO HEAR
IT BECAUSE HE HAS NEVHOWOHE LASC
CORONAVIRUS BUT TODAY THE
D SECURI RM A PTE
MONUMENTS, RI
STATUTESRUMP HASOWED THEYN' BOVR
THREATENING TO VETOSE  A INCLUDS
A PROVISION TO RENAMEITARY
SEAM CONFEDERATE
LES. THE BILLDES RAISIIE PRESS
SECRETD TRUMP I
SERIOUS ABOUT
>> THE PNT BEGNING LEGISLATION .
>> Reporter:TRUMP'SITICAL
ADVISERS FEAR HE IISTRACTED
HE
THE COUNTRY AS HEO  TAY OF
RUIA PAY THE
KILL.S. SARE FAKE.
>> I AGREE WITHEPEI THEEOPLE DIK
IT WAS SOMETHING THATVEPP BUT H
STD INTERAGENCY PROCESS
TO LOOK AT OPTIOOT IELUT TO
BE RI CLD
WE'D H
OPO TNT
WITH TO ARESIAN
SITUATION.
MAKERS HAVE BEEN
CALLING FOR MORE INFORMATION
ABOUT WHATHEELE
AGENCIES KNONDF TORG TO B THE H
GOING ON.
THS B THEAN  THEONAL
LEADERS FROM BOTH  AND  OFNT
COMMITTEES, AND GIVEN BY SOMEICR
FROM.IATOROF SECURITY
AND THE
NATIONAL INTELLIGE WILL ALSORE
BRIEFING ABOUT 1 ON RANK YOU SO.
>>JO US NOW DEMOCRATIC
CONGRESSMAN SETH MOLTEN OF
MASETTSD IN IRAQ
AS PR WITHE
U.S.CONGREMA FOR  SAID TOD WAY T
TRUM H THE ENT
COROQUOT
OUSLY TAS THET CRIMEAN COMMIT
AGAINSTOU
HOW ISS T
>>'SIDING AND ABETTING OUR
RUSSIA IS OUR E. TALIB IOF THE
WHATHE HAS DONE WITHTSILENC HIS
DE OF DUTY TAKE OURUTELY
AIDI OMY. ALS SAID THAT
AMERICAN AREAU
OF PRESIDENT'SCT
AS UNDERSTAND IT, INTELLIGENCE
IS S INVESTIGATINGHETHER
OR NOT THEES CAN BE ANY SPECIFI
ATTACK T AN
MARINES THEY A LOOKING AT.E YOU
LEVEL OF BME ONNTLI VERIFIED?
>> I'MVERYTHIN KELER A
HUAY?
HAVENT
CERTAINTY TT WAS IN THAT
COMPOUND IN POMMAND
DECI T
ASMANDER
RECEIVED A MY AMBUSHEDLO UMID I
LD
VEHICLES, PERPSD IT IST HUNDREDN
AND MY PLO,
E ENDING
LF BE BEC
THAT I THE BASICEVEL OF
AND R
OF THE MT JUNIOR O IN
OUR MILITARY. T THAT ASS T
ULTITE OF DUTY I HAVE A L I
MILITARY, NNG LIKE YOU
OF COURS ONE O
THE FIRSTCTIONS G WAS A WHOSE SN
IN AFGHANISTAN AND SHE JUST SID
ALTHOUGH RUSSIANSLLIS N E BUT
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S TI, MOST ABOU.
I KNOW ANYT A IWE STILL HAVEET
ANYTHING.
HE IS ATTACKING THE AND NTTACKI
PUTIN OR THE GRULYD MEAN,OD REAS
THE "NEW  HE
DOESN'T SEEM TO READ HISINTELL
NE
MADE THIS STORY PUBLIC OUR KNOW.
WE ALSO HEARD MIKE POMPEO TRYING
THIS
K THAN THAT.
WE OUGHT TOHAT DID
KE KWH THETARY OFDEFENSES PERKNE
PRESIDENT PENCE KNOW? TE
TO TROOPS BECAUSE
EVERY MO OITH A SON OGHTER FRONN
THAT PEOPLE A THE HIGST CHAIN O.
OKAY?
DII DISAD WAR EVENGH I WAS FIGG
ME ANDE. IS T F
>> I WANT TO GET YOURCT
TO A CLAIM PRESI TTOMMENT
FOX BUSESS. LISTE
ROR
ITREY THE INTELLINC
PEOPLE DIDN'T EVEN -- MANY
THEM DIDN'T BELIEVE IT HAPPENED
ATLLI THINK IT'S A THINKHE
NE DEMOC.>> YOUR RESPONSE, SIR?
>> IT ISTT MANY PEOPLE
BELIEVE IT ORN'T MATTER IF IS A
HUNDRED PERCENIFIED.
YOU ARE THE ANDER-IN-CHIEF
YOU'ES T LIVES
OF AMERICANS.YOU DO PER KEEP SAD
NOTHING.
WHY?
CAE ISON LIA RE ABOUTIS
PON
OFMER AMERICANT D DODGERS LIKE
THEIR LIVES ON THE FOR OUR
COUNTR O CONSTITUTION, AND S.
I THINKVE AMERICAN INCLUNGCAN SE
DEFCTPRESIDENT